bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions ce matin en direct sur arte
france comment est la vie en ce moment à
orane on le rappelle 1 3900 personnes
sont officiellement mort du corps un
navire russe l'hiver dernier qu'est ce
que vous en tant que médecin basé à
orane vous constatez sur le terrain eh
bien je constate que la vie a en fait a
repris quasiment normalement à partir du
8 avril déjà la date du déconfinement
delà de la ville de mourad
alors bien sûr les chinois ont été
extrêmement effrayée par cette épidémie
ils ont mis du temps à reprendre une vie
normale il a fallu que les autorités de
fait les 11 millions de yuans et à la
fin du mois de mai pour que la
population comprenne qu'on était
vraiment passé en dessous du seuil
épidémique et que reprendre une vie
normale donc lui en effet aujourd'hui on
est à ur à en masquer la vie économique
a repris normalement sans peur d'une
deuxième vague du côté de roanne alors
qu'elle aura pro confine ça veut dire
que la chine est en train de maîtriser
la situation
la chine a maîtrisé la situation en fait
au mois de février au mois de mars est
aujourd'hui bien sûr la chine est en
état de d'hypervigilance elle est
extrêmement attentive à ce qu'il n'y ait
pas une une résurgence une seconde vague
de dépit des 10 notamment grâce à tous
les moyens que ce que ce qui est moyen
d'intelligence artificielle les moyens
ni au testing ils sont capables de
bloquer une ville si lorsqu'il ya
quelques cas tous les cas aujourd'hui en
chine sont des cas importés
quelle énorme pression depuis
l'extérieur de la chine puisque la
pandémie repart notamment d'un
gouverneur avec le froid
il ya une énorme pression autour de la
chine et pourrait aussi des mesures
extrêmement drastiques pour empêcher que
le virus ne revienne sur le territoire
national et que l'épidémie de repas en
chine
donc la situation est maîtrisée par la
chine alors que la pandémie fait des
ravages en europe en ce moment quelles
différences majeures de gestion de la
pandémie entre pékin et les capitales
occidentales
et bien c'est au départ de l'événement
lorsque moi j'ai lancé l' alerte au mois
deux à la fin du mois de mars ça suffit
d'expliquer qu'il fallait prendre des
mesures en tout cas avoir de l'ouverture
d'esprit et puis regardez ce que les
chinois faisait
pour non pas freiner le phénomène mais
vraiment je le maîtrisais l'arrêté de
façon à ne pas le subir
lorsque les chinois des consignes le 8
avril il n'y a plus de personnes
infectées ou en tout cas il ya encore
quelques personnes asymptomatiques
infectés mais ils vont contrôler par le
par l'intelligence artificielle par le
testing de façon à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
de résurgence de de l'épidémie sur le
territoire chinois
merci philippe rien d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin basé à haoran enchaîne donc